et on va en parler justement ces
inondations et la situation que connaît
votre département mais aussi celui du
Nord Mathias d'abord on fait un point
sur les inondations n estv ou on a tous
vu ces terribles images Orian plus de 6
mois depuis se sont abatttu sur le Pas
de Calais en l'espace de 30 jours créant
d'importantes inondations les plus
importantes du siècle selon plusieurs
observateurs les zones sinistrées ont
doublement souffert puisqu'elles étaient
déjà fragilisées par le passage des
tempêtes Karan et Domingos dans les
semaines qui ont précédé plus de 5000
habitations touchées sur le seul
département du Pas decalais c'est donc
naturellement que l'état de catastrophe
naturelle a été déclaré dans 24 communes
qui en avaient fait la demande 214 dans
le pas decaletis 30 dans le département
du Nord mais aucune en Normandie ou en
Bretagne sous prétexte que les dégâts
causés par le vent n'entrent pas en
ligne de compte et Emmanuel Macron a
annoncé mardi un fond de soutien oui une
première enveloppe a été annoncé par le
président de la République lors de son
déplacement mardi à Saint-Omer Orian un
fond de soutien exceptionnel de 50
millions d'euros à destination des
communes pour répondre dans l'urgence
aux premières dépenses que vont
engendrer les dégâts causés par ces
inondations une aide qui sera selon les
dir d'Emmanuel Macron évolutive en
fonction de la situation dans les
communes touchées ce ne sera pas le seul
geste fait par l'état de la Bretagne au
Haut- de France en passant par la
Normandie on parle de région agricole le
ministre de l'Agriculture justement Marc
fen était hier chez nos confrères de
franceino pour annoncer un soutien à la
ruralité là c'est un fond de 80 millions
d'euros qui permettra de couvrir à la
fois les pertes de récolte mais aussi
les pertes d'investissement qui seraient
pas couvertes par les les sujets
d'assurance on a fait un fond qui permet
d'éviter pardon de l'expression des
trous dans la raquette qu'on voit bien
qu'il y a toujours des sujets certains
perdent plutôt des investissements et du
matériel mais il y a il y a un taux
d'usure donc ils sont mal couverts par
les assurances et comment on peut les
les accompagner c'est avec des
investissements voilà deux enveloppes
dégainé vite mais qui ne suffiront pas
c'est donc une situation qui préoccupe
beaucoup les acteurs du territoire à
noter que la F Fédération des assureurs
estime l'étendue des dégâts à plus de
1,3 milliard d'euros un chiffre qui est
d'ailleurs certainement sous-évalué et
ça a fait l'objet de question hier au
Sénat oui trois questions posées par des
sénateurs des haute France madame AP
poursopoli qui est présente ici
Jean-François Rapin pour leslr et la
centriste Amel gaker ont notamment
demandé d'une seule voix plus de
souplesse administrative en faveur des
mires pour permettre de prévenir les
conséquences dramatiques de ces
phénomènes climatiques au-delà de la
solidarité des collectivités locales qui
est déjà précisée et qui va s'accroître
au-delà de la solidarité nationale qui
est pleinement assuré dans l'urgence par
nos préfets et leurs services la
représentation nationale et les
collectivités attend des précisions pour
le futur de ces sinistrés juridiquement
ensuite les élus dont je salue
l'investissement entier auprès de leurs
administrati vous demande encore de
leurs administré pardon vous demande
encore de la souplesse dans l'exercice
de leur compéten faciliter l'entretien
des cours d'eau par exemple des faussés
ils sont encadrés par trop de normes et
de contraintes qui tiennent
essentiellement des conditions
environnementales excessives voilà
réponse du ministre de la transition
écologique Christophe béchou le
gouvernement a transmis hier au Conseil
d'État une procédure de simplification
pour le curage des rivières c'est le
fait de retirer le sédiment pour
permettre un meilleur écoulement une
proposition qui pourrait donner de
meilleurs moyens d'action aux élus sur
le terrain Frédéric Dané question
peut-être un peu dure pour commencer
allez-y tout ce sont ce sont des c'est
une crue qui est historique est-ce que
c'était anticipable voir évitable
évitable pas du tout anticipable non euh
on s'était tous basés à l'époque à
l'époque dans le territoire sur la crue
de 2002 et tous les modèles de prévision
étaient basé sur cette crue de 2002 les
pompes dans la région des wateratingues
étaient dimensionné pour une crue de
2002 et là on est à 50 % en plus et on a
une conjonction de phénomène qu'on
pouvait pas prévoir des pluies avant
beaucoup de pluies pendant des vents
d'ouest démarrer un peu forte ça plus la
enfin faut quand même rappeler que ce
territoire de toute façon est à fleur
d'eau h à l'ouest de l'UR Toie du côté
de Boulogne c'est un territoire qui euh
voilà qui a très peu de topographie
c'est un territoire qui était largement
urbanisé c'est un territoire argileux
donc dès qu'une goutte d'eau tombe bah
elle est vite absorbée et puis si la
deuxième goutte qui arrive elle est vite
voilà elle elle ruisselle vite même sur
les terres les plus absorbantes tel que
les prairies puis à l'Est on a la région
des wating qui depuis 1000 ans est sous
le niveau de la mer on est à 2,2 m sous
niveau de la mer et d'ailleurs la
production agricole notamment le
choufleur de Saint-Omer qui se fait là
c'est une production qui dépend de cette
inondation permanente qu'on dont on
adapte le niveau en jouant sur les
pompes et cetera donc pourit finir de
répondre à votre question est-ce que
c'était prévisible non est-ce qu'on
était préparé oui largement pour ça les
récriminations de certains là je les
trouve assez étrange d'aller c'est pas
parce qu'on va curer Trois Rivières que
ça va régler le problème non c'est un
pisalé et c'est d'autant plus étrange de
revendiquer ça au Sénat que les Maes
mines de de rien ont fait leur boulot ce
qu'on voit aujourd'hui aurait été bien
pire bien bien pire s'il y avait pas eu
tout ce qui avait ce qui a été fait
depuis 2017 grâce à la loi gmapi ouais
don donc pour vous juste l'annonce de
Christophe Béchu hier qui dit qu'il a
transmis un projet de simplification d'
curage des rivières au Sénat c'est bah
c'est rien du tout mais en terme de
volume c'est rien du tout alors
effectivement effectivement il faut
voilà il faut enfin c'est c'est c'est
compliqué d'aller draguer une rivière
pour des questions environnementales ça
dépend de l'fb mais ça va pas régler le
problème ENF le problème si vraiment on
veut faciliter la vie des maires qu'on
donne enfin des sous pour que les pompes
dans la région des watatingues un soit
changé ell l'ont ét en parti et surtout
que l'État Vienne payer la facture
d'électricité c'est un million d'euros
depuis 15 jours pour faire fonctionner
les pompes et à mon avis les syndicats
de rivière aont pas les moyens de régler
la facture voilà c'est là on peut mettre
des sous ouais on va en reparler sur sur
le le curage du coup ce que vous a
annoncé hier Christophe Béchu ça vous
satisfait pas non plus comme
réponse je pense que d'abord oui
monsieur a eu raison de féliciter et de
dire que les maires ont beaucoup donné
dans ce département il donne beaucoup ce
n'est pas la les premières inondations
que l'on a mais en tous les cas c'est
évidemment la première aussi impactante
pour le territoire je pense que les
puits torrentiel qu'on a eu après la
tempête faut-il le répéter parce que ce
sont deux catastrophes successives que
nous avons eu à à gérer et la tempête
dans un premier temps où il y avait déjà
des dégâts et les pluies torrencielles
moi je pense qu'il faut aujourd'hui nous
l'avons dit hier au au Sénat mais nous
le disons depuis le début il faut
simplifier la vie aux m quand même alors
moi
j'entends que le curage ne va pas
suffire mais en tous les cas ça peut y
participer euh il faut que les pompes
tournent il faut changer certaines
pompes pour en mettre des plus
puissantes il faut travailler avec à à
des bassins de rétention d'eau parce que
nous n'avons pas assez dans ce pas
decalé de bassin à rétention d'eau voyez
moi par exemple j'habite le bassin
minier j'étais régulièrement dans ma
ville inondée nous avons fait des
bassins de rétention je ne suis plus
inondée donc je ne dis pas que ça va
tout régler mais en tous les cas ça y
participe le curage démarré les pompes
entretenues les bassins de rétention
je pense que plus que jamais il faut
réfléchir à ces solutions les les
bassins de raison son doau c'est c'est
une réponse bah c'est une des réponse et
c'est ce qui explique que les
conséquences ne sont pas aussi
importantes qu'elles auraient dû qu'ell
l'uraient été s'il n'y avait pas eu la
loi gmapi en quelques mots la loi g
c'est un transfert de la responsabilité
sur les collectivités de la prévention
des inondations donc tous les maires ont
hurlé en disant on va pas y arriver mine
de rien ça leur a permis de lever une
taxe sur la taxe foncière qui a permis
dans le Boulonnais depuis 2017 de
financer des ouvrages de rétention et
aussi d'aider avec l'agence de l'eau les
agriculteurs à se souvenir que les était
pas si mal que les levés de terre
c'était pas si mal à l'époque pour pour
pour se garantir contre l'intensité des
inondations en tout cas oui des bassins
de rétention ont été construits
manifestement pas assez notamment en
amont des fleuves en particulier en
amont de laa le côté exceptionnel juste
un mot pour vous dire là où on en est
c'est qu'à la source de la a normalement
une rivière ne déborde pas à sa source
et là non seulement elle déborde ça veut
dire qu'il PE beaucoup mais l' ruisselle
ça veut dire qu'on a beaucoup trop
étanchifié qu'on a beaucoup trop
urbanisé à la source de là et ça c'est
assez exceptionnel et quand ça déborde
en haut bah vous imaginez ce qui se
passe en bas on peut plus rien arrêter
oui
oui sur ça et sur la loi g Mapie aussi
que je vous voyez réagir ouais moi
j'aimerais dire deux trois choses quand
même on est dans un changement
climatique il est'est on le voit de
partout il y a ce changement à prendre
en considération on a eu d'ailleurs on
était inquiet en septembre octobre il
faisait très beau hein donc on a aussi
les sécheresses dans le pas decalé des
terrains argileux et évidemment l'eau
s'évacue moins vite parce que nous avons
eu des périodes de sécheresse importante
qui ont empêché aussi l'infiltration des
eaux sur la loi gmapi euh ce sont les
gens je rappelle qui payent tous les
mois tous les ans excusez-moi il y a une
taxe qui doit être entre 34 40 €
approximativement euh ce n'est quand
même pas normal vous m'excusez que seul
les gens qui habitent dans ces
territoires payent moi je pense que ça
devrait être prise en charge par l'État
il nous faut beaucoup plus de moyens
parce que finalement et bien les gens du
Boulonnais de l'odomarois sont victime
d'habiter ces zones puisque nous nous ne
payons pas et eux payent donc ce serait
voilà normalement à l'état de prendre en
charge et euh c'est ce que j'aimerais
dire pour l'instant ouais et sur sur
l'artificialisation aussi des des zones
dont parlait Frédéric doné est-ce qu'
est-ce qu'il faut revoir ça certainement
qu'il y a des choses à à à faire et à
revoir aujourd'hui nombre de mè moi
voyez j'ai eu la mère de Saint-Étienne
auont d'c et cetera les centre-villees
sont inondées hein d'abord quand même on
est dans une situation où il y a
j'aimerais dire quand même qu'il y a
beaucoup de solidarité c'est important
parce que parfois on nous dit les
Français ne sont plus solidaires et
cetera il y a beaucoup de solidarité et
dans le pas decalais et nationalement
moi il y a pas un jour où je ne reçois
pas un coup de fil d'un maire de région
parisienne ou d'ailleurs qui veut
apporter concrètement sa solidarité au
pas decalé alors oui il faut
certainement revoir les choses les mes
sont inondés les centre-villes sont
inondé euh peut-être qu'il faut regarder
les choses parce qu'ils me disent aussi
qu'on est monsieur l'a dit mais nous
sommes dans des cuvettes et nous sommes
finalement dans une situation où l'eau
ne n'arrive pas à s'évacuer on le voit
ça descend vraiment très difficilement
quoi l'eau stagne elle ne descend pas
donc c'est un vrai problème et et
justement Emmanuel Macron a confié au
maire de Saint-Omer ou pas cela don dont
vous parlez fré Cain lui apparemment il
était sur toutes les photos le maire de
Saint-Omer ah ben il est allé à santomè
Emmanuel Macron il lu a confié une
mission pour améliorer l'évacuation vers
la mer des cours d'eau les plus à risque
oui bon non non mais c'est bien c'est
gentil bon c'est par il y a une question
politique M dans rien maire de
Saint-Omer était partout même dans les
vill dont il est pas le maire bon enfin
bref question politique c'est assez
amusant mais oui réagir k fropolis non
mais c'est bien cette mission il y a des
syndicats de rivière il y a des EPTB il
y a enfin il y a l'agence de l'eau qui
s'en occupe déjà
donc comment améliorer la circulation de
l'eau vers la Meur on le sait déjà enfin
entretenir les canaux on le sait mettre
des pompes en tout cas les entretenir
payer la facture d'électricité ça n'a
l'air de rien mais il y a 2 ans il y
avait 600000 € de déficit dans le
syndicat qui gère les wating 600000 €
pour simplement faire fonctionner les
pompes alors aujourd'hui les pompes ont
été changé pour un montant de 12 million
d'euros et il y a un million de facture
d'électricité à payer donc oui c'est
très bien mais plus que ça c'est une
réflexion globale alors
l'étanchéification
elle est réelle mais toute façon même
dans un lie largement naturel l'eau
aurait continué à ruisseler parce que
quand vous avez l'équivalent de aller
d'une baignoire et dememi qui vous tombe
au bout de 15 jours en 15 jours sur 1
m²r pouvez rien faire que vous ayez du
macadam ou de la terre la terre est un
bibon on ne peut rien faire du
tout la réflexion globale à avoir c'est
de se souvenir que dans une région la
topographie est très faible il faut
faciliter la circulation de l'eau donc
quand une rivière elle fait ça alors que
pendant 30 ans on lui a on lui a obligé
à faire ça c'est-à-dire à la canaliser
bah faut se souvenir que c'est peut-être
pas très très bon et qu'une rivière si
elle est devenue un canal elle va
retrouver de toute façon son cours d'eau
un moment ou un autre ce qui fait qu'on
a des routes qui ont été soulevés donc
pensez à la circulation de l'eau
repensez que l'eau retrouve toujours son
lit pensez au au aux courbes de niveau
parce qu'elles existent or on a
construit les acs on a construit les
routes on a construit les maisons
partout où l'eau se trouve et partout où
l'eau ne demande qu'à remonter à
l'occasion d'une PL important c'est
vraiment du réaménagement du territoire
et ça va prendre des années et des
années h ouais mais oui il y a ben il y
a l'avant il y a ce qui se passe
actuellement et puis il y aura un après
et moi ce qui m'importe aujourd'hui
c'est l'après parce que finalement là
voilà on est dans une situation où on
l'a subi et et juste sur le P sur le
pendant pardon ka propoli est-ce que
vous êtes inquiète des conséquences de
l'eau qui stagne en ce moment dans votre
département bien sûr c'est une
inquiétude que l' stagne alors je pense
et j'espère que ça ça ça va s'évacuer au
fur à mesure mais par exemple vous voyez
on est victime d'une chose aujourd'hui
c'est qu'on ne peut plus se servir de
l'eau du robinet hein voilà donc on est
en train de distribuer aux gens des
bouteilles d'eau alors vous imaginez des
familles où il y a deux trois enfants
mais même quand on est deux quand on est
un quoi on vous distribue des bouteilles
d'eau et cetera c'est un vrai souci on
l'a dit tout à l'heure les beau vins les
gens parce que les gens finalement là
sont pour certains je je peux le dire
comme ça je pense au bord du désespoir
parce que quand vous rentrez quand vous
ne pouvez plus rentrer chez vous d'abord
quand vous ne pouvez plus rentrer chez
vous mais en plus de ça quand vous voyez
votre maison qui est complètement
inondée ù même des bottes ne suffisent
pas parce que c'est bien au-dessus des
bottes vous êtes désespéré la répétition
les maires qui finalement ont été jour
et nuit avec leur population durant des
des jours et des nuits où les service
public parce que j'avais le maire d'Arc
hier au téléphone il me disait tu sais
Cathy j'ai deux écoles que je dois
recaser ailleurs pour l'instant donc
c'est remettre des classes dans les
écoles existantes tout ça c'est un un un
un un souci et un casse-tête pour les
maires en plus des habitants qui
viennent les voir pour demander des
solutions parce que quand on est maire
vous m'excusez mais quand on est mère on
le fait avec passion et voir les
habitants
venir sans cesse ça ça ça ça prend au
moral d'ailleurs on a bien vu qu'il y a
un MRE qui jette l'éponge désespéré non
mais désespéré parce que c'est dur ouais
Frédéric dans et peut-être sur cette
question de la stagnation de l'eau et
après on parlera de ce qu'on peut faire
ce qui fait àétrouger don don peut
s'inspirer bah oui l'eau va stagner elle
va finir par s'évacuer après on aura
aller faire auetour c'est qu'il va plus
pleuvoir les ternes ne seront plus
imbibé mais les nabes vont se décharger
dans les rivières moment parce qu'elles
sont connectées faut jamais l'oublier
quand p est archi pleine si la rivière
est un peu moins elle va se décharger
dedans donc on n pas fini on n pas fini
d'en voir le bout ce qui me fait dire
moi que dans certains territoire dans
certains creux de vallée je me demande
si les assureurs vont vouloir encore
assurer des maisons en attendant qu'un
réaménagement hypothétique du territoire
fasse en sorte et que la construction
effectivement nouvelle bassin
appelonsles comme ça de retenu comment
dirais ne limite l'importance des crues
mais il y a il y a des endroits où il y
a des villes des villages où il devit
devenir quasiment impossible d'habiter
parce que ces
crusont se répéter vont se répéter
est-ce qu'il y a des exemples à
l'étranger dont on pourrait s'inspirer
pour l'aménagement du territoire bah
c'est toujours l'exemple c'est la tarte
à la crème de la Hollande hein qui a
connu des des submersions pardon
gigantesque à la fois à cause de l'eau
de mer et à cause de l'eau de pluie la
Hollande bah c'est comme la région des
wateringes elle est sous le niveau de la
mer alors c'est un bon exemple mais on n
pas trop à rougir nous en France enfin
la gestion de l'eau globalement elle est
assez exemplaire et elle a été encore
une fois accélérée par la loi gap je
reondis sur ce que vous disiez la loi
gmapi a eu un mérite c'est de
responsabiliter les gens responsabiliser
les gens notamment les élus c'est de
leur redonner une culture du risque donc
quand vous dites c'est pas normal que
les gens payent quand ils sont en zone
inondable si c'est normal qu'il payent
un peu plus parce que le signal prix
parce que lié à la loi gmapi il donne
une idée il donne une idée du risque est
devant nos portes ce risque avait été
oublié dans la région il y a une crue en
2002 il y avait une crue de la Somme en
2003 très bien d'ailleurs on avait
accusé Paris d' avir inonderé la somme
souvenez-vous et là d'ailleurs on accuse
d'unkerer pour avoir préservé d'unkerer
qu'on a laissé inonderé saintomè ça
revient toujours la recherche du
bouissaire mais on avait oublié bah
finalement avec la loi jimapi on se dit
que ouais si on paye sur notre taxe
foncière c'est qu'il y a un risque qui
est toujours présent malgré tout malgré
tout je sais plus ce que je voulais dire
j'ai pas mais ça va vous allez le
retrouver est-ce que pour pour rebondir
sur ce que disait Frédéric Danet vous
êtes inquiet de la question de
l'habitabilité de ces zones est-ce qu'à
un moment vous dites mais chez moi dans
le Pas de Calais il va y avoir des zones
qui sont plus habitables euh je pense
qu'il va alors euh d'abord c'est un
débat et je pense qu'il faut non pas des
années mais il faut quand même prendre
le temps de se poser euh ça doit pas
durer des années il va falloir non mais
je suis évidemment d'accord avec vous je
ne demande pas à ce que ça prenne des
années je me dis que là dans les dans
les prochains mois ici là tout de suite
d'abord il faut régler le problème des
gens parce qu'on a des gens qu'on doit
reloger hein c'est pas rien quand une
commune doit trouver 30 40 50 logement
d'urgence alors qu'on est dans des
villages dans des villes de 6000 ou
10000 habitants c'est pas c'est pas
évident et puis vous savez quand les
gens sont habitués dans une ville on va
pas demander à des gens d'habiter à à
100 km de là quand ils ont des enfants
dans cette école ou quand ils
fréquentent la crèche donc il faut
régler ce problème moi je dis qu'il faut
tout de suite se poser avec le président
de la région les présidents du
département
du Nord et du Pascal celui du du
Pascalis le président du Département du
Pascalis et Xavier Bertrand d'ailleurs
pour le nord et Jean-Claude Leroi ont
fait des propositions concrètes ils
disent qu'il faut aller très vite il
faut aussi se poser tout de suite sur le
territoire avoir des réunions d'urgence
avec les maires qui connaissent leur
territoire il ne faut pas qu'il y ait
une personne
providentielle qui arrive si
Macron décide pour l'ensemble il est
sarcastique ce matin un mot de
conclusionaime bien de temps en temps un
mot de conclusion mais en fait c'est un
mot que m'avait dit Emmanuel le roi la
duie quand j'avais travaillé avec lui il
m'avait dit l'eau c'est le premier tueur
en série de l'histoire parce que face à
l'au ne peut rien faire face à un
incendie on peut se protéger un
tremblement de terre bon bah voilà c'est
comme ça mais face à l' on peut rien
faire du tout et l' réveille des peurs à
ta vie et l' effectivement quand elle
arrive dans une maison quand elle arrive
dans un village c'est c'est c'est c'est
la destruction d'une intimité c'est très
bien mais on peut s'adapter et on
s'adapte déjà VO c'est pompiers qui me
disent ça l'eau l'eau parce que je tiens
quand même à saluer tous les services
l'État les pompiers tous ceux qui ont
qui ont participé à essayer ouais on va
continuer à parler de ce sujet parce
que ouis c'est fini mais c'est dans la
précipiter donc non non mais vraiment
super boulot de la Voix du Nord on va
regarder tout ça
[Musique]
justement à la une de nos quotidiens
régionaux ce sont ces intempérés oui la
Voix du Nord on l'a vu tout à l'heure
avec Julien l'écuyer La Voix du Nord qui
a décidé de rendre hommage à toutes
seelles et ceux qui ont prêté mains
fortte lors de ce terrible épisode
climatique soignant secours bénévole ils
subissent il secours il soignent il
surveill dans l'eau la tête haute titre
le journal nordiste à la Une de cette
série de portrait de ces femmes et
hommes qui et femmes et hommes pardon
qui continuent encore de se battre dans
ces moments difficile et pendant que
certains luttent contre les éléments
d'autres tirent la langue oui des elpes
Maritimes au Var les les thermomètres
per le Nord Orian pratiquement 28 degr à
Canne hier 27 à Mandelieu l'été en
novembre comme titre ni ce matin a l'air
de ravir ses baigneurs à la Une il
faudrait leur rappeler que pareille
température à cette époque de l'année
bien c'esttat normal Mathias vous allez
aussi nous parler de mat oui la France
Estelle réellement un pays de cancre en
mathématique comme l'évoque La Dépêche
du Midi rapidement Rian 6 x 7 42 ouais
42 Gabriel s'est montré inquiet suite au
résultats des évaluations nationales en
français et en mat passé septembre par
les élèves de 4e le journal toulousin
recueille le témoignage de professeur
qui estime que le niveau d'exigence a
baissé le ministre de l'éducation
nationale a promis des mesures fortes
début décembre à commencer par l'
resturation de groupe de niveau on parle
20 également oui le 3e jeudi de novembre
Orian c'est le jour du beau Jolet
nouveau rien à voir événement
incontournable à Lyon le progrès met en
avant un millésime 2023 joyeux et
combatif on sait pas trop ce que ça bien
vouloir dire à propos d'un on ira
enquêter un petit conseil quand même
avec un un saucisson chaud des patates
chaud et de la sauce bourguignonne c'est
excellent ah ouais je compte sur vous
pour enquêter un mot sur les langues
régionales ouais très
trs exactement une fois par en le
Courrier Picard mais à l'honneur le
Picard vous connaissez notre attachement
au territoirean donc quoi de plus local
que VO la une on fait lireilà si
quelqu'un arrive à la lire ditber
d' et voilà c'est vous êtes par moi je
ser pas Aventur vous êtes parfait on
aurait pu vous faire une émission entil
hein écoutez ce sera pour ce sera pour
une prochaine fois vous revenez tous les
deux merci beaucoup merci d'avoir été
avec nous Frédérique dans Katia
poursopoli merci mati merci à tous de
nous avoir suivi on se retrouve demain
bonne
journée